mid Samar is a movie about a
relationship going up in flames
literally writer-director re aster has
described it as more of a breakup movie
than a horror film one that he hopes
will leave people quote feeling a little
bit confused about how to feel so what
happened as aster has explained in many
interviews mid Samar is about a
relationship coming to an end
he told USA Today the goal was
ultimately to make a big operatic
breakup movie that feels the way
breakups actually feel catastrophic like
the world is ending
it's an operatic breakup movie and and a
dark contemporary fairy tale like a lot
of great horror movies you're not really
supposed to take everything that happens
in mid Samar literally whether all of
this weird stuff is actually happening
isn't nearly as important as how the
characters react to it particularly
Danny altered states and hallucinations
play a big role in mid Samar story and
subjectivity is important to how the
plot unfolds from Danny's perspective
the story plays out as a series of
increasingly shocking revelations the
movie looks a lot different from the
perspective of Pella the member of the
Horgan commune out of all of Christians
friends who come to the orga festival
he's the only one who knows what's going
to happen that's why you look so guilty
right now because you know the audience
also gets competing perspectives of
Danny and Christians relationship the
audience sees Danny going through an
incredibly traumatic time meeting the
support of a loved one more than ever
but we also get a look at Christians
perspective seeing a guy who's falling
out of love with his girlfriend and
tired of dealing with her drama whether
any of it is her fault or not
complicating matters are Christians
friends most of whom clearly don't like
Danny and are encouraging Christian to
pull away you've been wanting out of
this stupid relationship for like a year
now
Danny spends most of the movie as a
passive protagonist mostly only reacting
to events as they happen she doesn't
want to be a needy person and bends over
backwards to take the blame for her own
clinginess
always going with the flow in hopes of
salvaging her relationship so she ends
up on a trip she didn't plan under the
influence of hallucinogens she didn't
tend to take she gives and she gives
hoping all the while that Christian his
friends or the world in general will
just give her a break nothing our life
feels in her grasp until the end of the
movie when she's finally crowned the May
Queen and given ultimate power over the
commune after spending the whole movie
as a doormat for Christian and his
friends she ends up symbolically at
least in control of their fates in
Midsomer flowers represent family with
an early clue to the symbolism being the
floral wallpaper in the bedroom of
Danny's parents seemed just before they
died the metaphor can be extended to
plants in general after the death of
Danny's family the house plants in her
apartment are all dead in the beginning
of the movie Danny's world is dark and
frigid but things began turning around
for her on the trip in a place where the
Sun rarely stops shining and flowers
grow in abundance before Danny even
consciously realizes it she's being
introduced to a new family the first
person to wish Danny a happy birthday
the first birthday she's celebrating
without her family is Pella Danny truly
begins being pulled into the cult on the
final day when she joins in the
drug-fueled dance around the Maypole for
the competition she's gifted a flowered
wreath after she wins and becomes the
maid queen she soon seen literally up to
her neck in flowers all but smothered by
the [ __ ] Gazette eration her brothers
and sisters if she'll have them it's a
mutually beneficial relationship the
commune often needs outside members in
order to avoid inbreeding and Danny
needs a new place to belong for old
families lives were violently ended her
new family as a violent start mid
Samar's violent yet somehow serene
ending works on one level as classic
Wicker Man style folk horror but it's
also a strong metaphor for a dissolving
relationship early on in the movie Danny
a psychology student makes reference to
the psychological process of a breakup
seeing the signs of her dissolving
relationship in Christians distancing
behavior in that sense the whole bonkers
final sequence can be read as a
ritualistic look at how a relationship
comes to an end as the movie begins its
third act both Danny and Christian alien
and agitate their friends with their
relationship woes they become separated
experiencing different parts of the
festival on their own Christian goes
into a trance-like state as he cheats on
Danny with Maya the commune grown signs
of being smitten with him ever since his
group arrived since we've seen him be
drugged and hexed to the point where his
mind seems blank there is a strong sense
that he is not doing this voluntarily
urged on by sheer physical desire rather
than conscious thought it's the exact
story we see in a hanging tapestry
earlier in the movie meanwhile Danny
goes dancing on her own unconcerned
about Christians whereabouts with a
little help from the harga the
long-suffering couple is finally coming
apart Danny starts the movie surrounded
by people who don't appreciate her grief
worried that they'll abandon her the
only people who show her kindness seem
to be Pella and the [ __ ] go after Danny
bears witness to Christian and Maya
together in their ritualistic tryst she
begins to emotionally break down as she
does so she's surrounded by followers of
the May Queen all emphatically mimicking
her every noise and emotion despite the
obvious pain of the moment this sense of
true connection and empathy is what
Danny has spent the movie looking for
she screams and everyone around her
screams back
unlike Christian or his friends they
share her pain ever since her family
died that's all she's really wanted one
of the more amusing aspects about mid
Samar's climax is the way the events
parallel fellow folk or film The Wicker
Man as well as that movie's certifiably
insane Nicolas Cage starring remake that
movie inexplicably involved cages
character dressing up in a bear costume
to disguise himself before eventually
just running around punching people a
fact that's impossible not to think
about when Christian is rendered
paralyzed and sewn into a bear carcass
of his own it's the same bear briefly
shown caged up on the commune grounds
earlier in the movie not having a clear
purpose until the movies bloody end
considering how much Astor has credited
the original wicker man with inspiring
mid samar it's not hard to read this
detail of the bear suit as an
intentional nod to the
remake adding a bit of dark absurdist
humor to the movies fiery climax as
Christian and the bodies of his friends
are being readied for ritual sacrifice
the proceedings are watched over by a
mysterious figure face and visible
behind a thick veil the script for mid
Samar names this character as veter the
god of vengeance but while this figure
obviously plays into some kind of [ __ ]
guerrilla he also serves as a metaphor
for Danny's emotional state
the man refers to Christian wrapped up
in the bear carcass as a quote mighty
and dreadful beast whose death will
purge the Hargis society of its quote
most unholy effects even though she may
not have ordered it deliberately this
destructive ritual can be read as a very
personal reaction on the part of Danny
on whose orders the commune is now
effectively acting whether she ordered
it or not this is an act of vengeance on
her behalf
after four years of dating and a long
slow with a ring of her romance with
Christian Danny is finally asserting
herself and guiding the relationship to
a permanent end after spending the whole
movie being passive this sequence
represents her consciously letting go
unleashing all of her pent-up
frustrations with Christian and his
friends to her relief and their doom
seeing her smile could come as a total
shock it's cathartic it's weird and it
doesn't make a ton of literal sense but
it does make sense emotionally making
for a haunting final sequence that as
Astor said he intended mainly viewers
perplexed about how they're supposed to
feel check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite horror movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]